what kind of reaction have you gotten
from being part of that I've been
preaching sexism in country music for a
while I like to stir the pot all right
I like some controversy right gets
people talking
yeah well yeah I love the song pig out
they released scares people
[Music]
that's the thing yeah you got a lot of
blowback from that like yeah what was
your take on the reaction to that song I
mean I expected it it's important to to
bring up issues like that because a lot
of people don't don't know anything
about it and it was something that I was
angry about for a while is there a point
where it's like should I just kind of
quote-unquote play the game in order to
get in order to be employed or you worry
about like I'm gonna lose out on
opportunities by speaking up too much I
mean I sure people will try to scare you
into not speaking your mind but that's
not the way that I got here speaking out
about music grow and about things that I
didn't like in the music industry and
that was how I got my foot in the door
so I don't really feel and you need to
like sugarcoat things right CMT nounce
they're gonna do a 52 people with male
female so do you feel like there might
be a change slowly happening of course I
hope for it I think that it's gonna be a
long time when until things are actually
even I hope things start to change but
as we've seen through history things
rarely get better
the other thing cannabis is now legal in
Canada incredible and you have a line
with Willie Nelson what's you know who
else do you want to do a cannabis life
with them boy Nelson I think out of all
the things I've accomplished that's up
there in the top how does that come
about there's a high idea
you know we had my smokes with Willie
several times and played a lot of shows
of them she sang on my album I'm gonna
slowly be expanding that because I think
people buy more records right okay yeah
it's analog